jalen horde haven't seen him really in
the first half shoots against two
the defense kaminga trying with the
handle now to bring it up
that's the value in kamehameha renee my
goodness that is and kaminga and i think
oliver actually got a hand on that as
well tough shot right there trying to
finish between those two
dominguez gonna get this last look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
[Applause]
we got to see that again don't reach
uh
that was it right there and then he took
off yakum watch your head boy
that's a pretty good way to end the
first half here at cox pavilion
wow i'm telling you that's something to
smile about right there and you know
they talk about him he's an exciting
player
they are excited to have this guy on the
roster yeah and i'm excited to be
calling this game because i can expect a
couple more highlights from him
throughout the game look at that looking
at the rim
we love to see it how about the handle
on this young pillar
that's beautiful and that's the thing
too to be able to get yourself we know
he's a high flyer but the handles to be
able to get yourself to the takeoff
position
that's it